nursing unions say a one percent pay
rise is pitiful but in a labor market
reshaped by covid
are they right nurses wanted a twelve
and a half percent rise
and this chart from the nuffield trust
demonstrates why
it shows pay compared to 2010 earnings
that is adjusted
for inflation and it reveals that a
decade of austerity pay caps
saw real terms earning for nurses fall
almost
10 percent that gap did start to close
after a three-year pay deal worth around
three percent was agreed in 2018.
the blue line the light blue line is
private sector earnings
they also dipped after the financial
crash but they recovered
before the pandemic struck but rishi
sunak is worried about another gap
between overall public and private
sector pay
when he announced a pay phrase for
everyone by our health care workers last
november he said this public sector
premium
was growing too fast you can see three
years ago the average weekly wage for
both public and private sector workers
was about 530 pounds now public pay
rises started to open the gap and it
grew when the pandemic
closed down chunks of the economy that's
this big gap here
but it had almost closed to parity at
the end of 2020
but private sector jobs are also much
less secure
new figures show more than eight million
people almost a
third of the workforce were highly
vulnerable to losing their jobs or
having their hours cut
during the first year of the pandemic
now the jobs likeliest to be affected
included construction workers security
guards
cleaners but healthcare workers were
among the least vulnerable
now many of the most economically
insecure workers are also the most
vulnerable to the disease we know
security guards
drivers retail workers all have elevated
covered risk
but so too of course the health and
social care workers
in truth the pandemic has blurred the
lines between public and private sector
pay
so far the state has spent 73 and a half
billion pounds on furlough and
self-employment support that's
effectively
nationalized millions of private sector
jobs and it's not
over yet by comparison one percent on
nurses salaries cost the treasury
around 500 million pounds whether to
spend it
isn't just a question of how we value
their work but it is
ultimately a political calculation